life can only be understood backwards
but it must be lived forwards millions
of people look to us for information and
uplift and yes entertainment and we're
gonna give it to him and action what is
it to be human what is it take what is
it to be alive each person you speak to
us had a day some of the days have been
good some bad each person you speak to
has had a childhood it has a body each
body has eggs look for what is special
about each individual focus on that
remember there is someone out there for
everyone our time is limited we forget
that every story ever told can be broken
down into three parts the beginning the
middle and the twist oh we're in a movie
but this is a horror movie and Billy
Murphy's really after all of us what
you're doing
sters demons sorry maybe they're
friendly not friendly definitely not
friendly come with me if you want to
live all right Scouts let's kick some
zombie ass okay I got this
why did you come and came here to kill
you you'll pick up to garden troll I
pick up
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 76
hunger game
the dark side Ajay they're real we're on
the force it's calling to you just got
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]